though we cannot have actual
real audiences because of of course the
covid
uh epidemic uh we do have cutouts i
mentioned this earlier in the week
random cutouts that we found in a
storage room
uh on the warner brothers lot uh here
they are
joining us a cutout of ruth bader
ginsburg the supreme court justice
uh conrad bane the father on different
strokes
we have a life-size six foot six cutout
of former fbi director
james comey and uh four
count them four kevin harts
so we got that all right we are not
alone also
i should point out she's either a cut
out or a real person my assistant sona
movesession sona oh you you i saw your
head move you are
the real sona yeah i'm real okay how are
you
i'm all right how are you you enjoy
being in the crowd is there a feeling of
electricity in that crowd
no it's kind of sad and lonely actually
a little depressing out here thank you
thank you for pumping up the show sona
great job
lonely and depressing everything i just
did
to create a sense of visceral excitement
now deflated right sona yeah yeah you
should it it's really just
there's nothing got it thank you
thank you good to have you here
as always i'm here we're good
uh just by myself okay we got it
all by yourself and depressed hey
guess what i think we're all feeling
that way don't you think sona do you
think a lot of people
are feeling a little down these days
yeah i think there's a lot of depression
yeah yeah i don't i can't hear you
through the mask uh you sound like one
of the
parents on a charlie brown cartoon
but anyway
you know we are in the middle of a
global pandemic no getting around that
and you may have seen a lot of the
critical data that's been
charted and graphed by the cdc okay and
that's fine that's good
we need science we need information but
as i've mentioned
some of the graphs that they're
releasing seem a little unnecessary
as far as i'm concerned for example i
don't know if you've seen this one
since march there's been a 98
increase in americans walking into their
living room stopping and saying
why did i come in here yeah there's been
a
68 increase in deciding not to learn
another language after all
there's been a 60 increase in horny guys
bragging that their oxygen
sat rates are through the roof bro
how these uh how are these so far sona
they're good
they're they're really but they're funny
nice job
hey there's been a 438 decrease in your
dog's interest in you
there's been a 70 increase in asking the
postmates person
to hold you gently there's been a
non-stop increase in aimless walks taken
it's been a significant increase in
americans saying might as well try that
elon musk brain chip and finally
a chart depicting my binges food
netflix and sex
see how that last one kind of the joke
was on me yeah
yeah that's yeah that was good
that was funny my own fault for asking
sona's opinion
no one needs to know no one needs to
know that and by the way
okay let's just say this guy
what anyway